Grégoire Bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
RTL France alors cette première question
pour quelle raison précise et 2 ex
détenus français de Guantanamo on saisit
la CEDH est-ce que la CEDH justement et
compétent pour juger ses affaires à
Guantanamo
il faut rappeler que pour saisir la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme il faut
d'avoir avoir épuisé les voies de
recours en France dans cette affaire
nous avons une ordonnance de non-lieu en
2017 confirmé par la Cour d'appel puis
par la Chambre criminelle de la Cour de
cassation au finalement c'est un peu
leur dernière solution Laura tu la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme mais il
faut pas s'attendre à de grande surprise
de la part de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme pourquoi parce que
pourquoi nous avons été face à une
blocage au niveau des juridictions
françaises en principe très important
droit international c'est le principe 10
minutes et des juridictions et ce
principe d'imiter juridiction
rappelons-le il dit très clairement que
les actes dans l'état et ranger les
actes souverain ne peuvent pas être jugé
par un État étranger c'est lui qui
voulait le fait d'avoir même si c'est
extrêmement condamna préjudiciable
d'avoir enlevé les personnes de les
avoir
mets dans un territoire comme Guantanamo
de la souveraineté des États-Unis
international ça ne peut pas être remis
en cause par le droit coutumier par les
conventions internationales mais
également par la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme donc là ils vont faire
face à une difficulté je leur ai dit que
importante
tueur présumé qui ont été fait à
l'encontre
il porte plainte aussi parce que là les
autorités françaises aurait utilisé leur
a veux obtenu selon sous la contrainte
est-ce que ça c'est audible devant
devant la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme
parce que c'est intéressant c'est que la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
elle a des Tendances est dans sa part
elle considère qu'elle ne peux rien
faire et on avait une tendance depuis
quelques années où elle revenait dessus
est considéré que parfois le droit pénal
les infractions pénales pouvez aller à
l'encontre de ce principe d'immunité de
juridiction mais on constate depuis
quelques temps que la Cour européenne
est revenu sur une approche une doctrine
assez conservatrice donc malgré les
éléments soulever à part les parties
civiles par les Antilles mais ça va être
assez difficile que la Cour européenne
évolue même si elle va considérer les
infractions été établi dans des
conditions que vous venez de soleil
est-ce que finalement ça a une portée
symbolique est-ce que on peut imaginer
comme ministration american regarde de
près ce que dit la CEDH
alors il faut pas être naïf en droit
international vous avez toutes les
conventions voudrais le principe
fondamental c'est quand même le rapport
de force
et les États-Unis sont dans un rapport
de force il refuse on se d'extra les
citoyens il refuse la coopération
internationale surtout cette sujet ils
ne sont pas signés terre pour la Cour
pénale internationale donc on ne pense
pas que la position américaine va
changer en revanche ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les États-Unis ont
décidé depuis quelques années de
réfléchir à l'avenir de Guantanamo vous
avez le Barack Obama qui fait une
promesse de campagne qui avait signé une
ordonnance en 2009 sur ce sujet
là mais pas suivi parce qu'elle est pas
c'était une mesure un populaire
aux États-Unis
Trump avait dit qu'il souhaitait
maintenir la prison
de la fermer
cette question est-ce que tu vas réussir
à faire le son président de l'époque on
utilise présent la pas réussi à faire
d'ici la fin de son mandat c'est un
engagement mais sans engagement
extrêmement compliqué juridiquement
parce qu'il faut trouver
sur quel droit on va mettre ses
prisonnier financièrement
ce
qui complique
principe fondamental du droit
et
maintenant de mettre un terme à
finalement c'est noir dans la réputation
au niveau international et un sujet
assez intéressant ça va être si un les
États-Unis arrive à fermer cette prison
de est-ce qu'ils vont aussi aller vers
des réparations parce que c'est ça
finalement si on veut vraiment boucler
la boucle reviens dans le droit chemin
si jamais des victimes 11 justement des
actes de torture qui sont condamnés à
part le droit américain est-ce que les
États-Unis accepteront ou pas de verser
de dommages-intérêts à ces personnes et
là ça serait vraiment un pas de plus
vers le retour à l'état de droit pour
les États-Unis
j'imagine pour tous les
à qui s
c'est c'est c'est un casse-tête
d'ailleurs il aura fallu des années de
stress pour que certains détenus puisse
avoir accès à un avocat parfois c'est
avocat dans pas eu accès aux pièces du
dossier
aucune possibilité de faire un recours
certains n'ont même pas encore été
entendu ou juger alors qu'ils sont dans
cette prison depuis des années après il
y a une réalité aussi en considération
il y a eu des centaines de prisonnier
dans cette prison il n'y aura plus que
des dizaines certains ont été
si je peux dire vers les États-Unis donc
globalement on ils sont en train de
régler progressivement ce problème et
l'ai prévenu ont eu les parties civiles
et de plus en plus se faire accompagner
par les avocats auprès des autorités
américaines merci beaucoup Grégoire je
le rappelle vous êtes avocat en droit
international